determine whether the statement is
always sometimes or never true and
explain why the statement here is b
squared plus b minus 2 all that over b
plus 2 is equal to b minus 1 for all
real numbers b
well one thing that just
jumps out at you before you even try to
manipulate this algebraically is that i
can think of a b value that where this
left expression won't be equal to b
minus 1 a b value that will make this
left expression undefined and it becomes
undefined if this denominator becomes
0 and the way the denominator is going
to become 0 is if b is negative 2. so
let's write that down if
b is equal to negative 2
then
b squared plus b
minus two over b plus two what does that
become it becomes it equals
b squared would be four minus two minus
two which would be zero over
zero
which
is undefined
undefined
not
it's not equal to
let me write this this way
it's not equal to it's not
equal
to b minus 1
which
is
negative 2 minus 1 negative 3. when you
put negative 2 in here you don't on the
left hand side you don't get it doesn't
evaluate to negative 3 it values to 0
over 0 which is undefined so we already
found an example of a b where this is
not true so it's definitely not always
going to be true we found a case now
let's algebraically manipulate this and
see if it's true for pretty much any
other number so let's let's see if we
can maybe factor the numerator up there
so b squared plus b minus 2 if you think
about it a number that two numbers when
you take their product is negative two
and when you add them you get one well
that's going to be positive two and
negative one so the numerator we can
rewrite as b
b plus two times b minus one and then
the denominator is b plus 2
and then and well we could just leave it
like that let's just work on the left
hand side now if we assume if we assume
that b is not equal to negative 2
then b plus 2 divided by b plus two is
well defined it is one and as long as
it's not zero zero it will be one and so
this expression is the same thing as b
minus one if we assume that b is not
equal to negative two
so if you assume that b is not equal to
negative two this thing over here does
indeed equal b minus 1. so it is true
for all of the other real numbers except
for negative 2. so this is sometimes
true it's true every time except for the
case where b is equal to negative two
you can even try it with some number
here try it with zero if i were to do
zero squared plus zero minus two you get
negative two over zero plus two is two
and then that does indeed equal
negative one so it works with zero it
works with one it works with any number
other than b is equal to negative two